oh dear
5 000 bits if you get your king to e4 in
the opening and don't lose
king 2 e4 don't lose
in the opening oh
ooh i have raised my offer to 25
000. good luck oh man
okay pick me
oh okay
too late um okay so this is a king e4
challenge
how do i even do this let's let's play
the same opening and let's see where
this goes
so the goal is to get king king e4 in
the opening and still win
uh play this
okay
i actually don't know how to do this
how do i do this so king
i could take twice i could move up right
away
let's actually push
clearing the square first
okay i'm getting ready it's going to be
the hyper
accelerated bond cloud of greatness
eric please just don't meet me for
you're welcome
move the king oh oh you're telling me
what to do
that's my goal
not so easy to prevent
oh dear do i do it
does black have forced mate
maybe but yolo yolo king e4 in the
opening
this is only the first step i have to
try and win i am looking at the
to get the analysis to e4 oh man i have
to play blind now
i have to play blind alright
diamond cutter such a troll uh
play king play king d4
and let's sound eric can you play the
tennis and gambit
speech start with knight speech is ready
[Music]
[Music]
hi youtube how's it going hope you're
doing well
wait is the texting active it is okay so
queen f4 so let's play d4
wait what why did not go oh it's not
uh my bad okay blindfold starting now
so d4 blocking the check some tension
between the pawns wait how much time
does black hat
knight c6 what one minute bishop takes
f4
okay that was that's just for the 985
check
that's really just what i needed from c3
king c3
[Music]
g3
c takes d4 queen takes d4
okay bishop d7
d7 let's play next c3
okay so my king's back on c2 good center
control
what bishop b4 there's a b4
let's take on d5 knight takes d5
e takes d5 d5 queen takes d5
queen side castles oh tricky
queen's like castles play rook c1 roxy
one
bishop c6
bishop c6 very tricky
am i queen trapped queen's almost
trapped a queen e6
queen e6 check check
white one minute five seconds
black king b8
play king king b1
oh my rook's hanging ooh
bishop takes h1
play queen play three
check king a2 ben
feingold just raided with 2
queen takes d5 rook takes d5
e6 check king a8
knight f3
rookie 8.
knight g5
rookie 7
[Music]
rook
there too let's go
wow 16 seconds left too wow
i tried playing b takes a5 wow sam
living up sam is 25 000 bits
hello and ken hands are shaking after
that one
yeah there's so many things that i kind
of missed but
made up for backgrounds
and i was about to play rook c8 before
like allowing rook takes c8 but then i
realized that the rank was open
man
thanks sam wow sam with a 50k bits badge
that was that was a difficult challenge
i was not expecting to do that blindfold
too
and diamond cutter wanted to make it
more difficult
yeah thanks thanks for the games my
opponents um
yeah bishop so bishop d5 is a good move
knight b3 maybe less good
yeah i think what happened here
was when i took on b3 i was envisioning
that for some reason i took on b4
like i knew both things were hanging
and i just forgot the bishop was here
thankfully it didn't really matter
um i was very lucky here
if black played a6 i've i probably would
have ended up flagging
i'm not sure though
uh thanks everyone yeah i'll probably
put that
on on youtube the hyper
accelerated bond cloud blindfold